part two of our reaction to the boys
season two finale people if you missed
part one make sure to go ahead watch
that first link in the description box
and pin
comment in the meantime enjoy
you guys ready yeah
of course i dance what is the point of
life without dancing
i am so french
already an intense international
i can't believe i actually have to say
this this day and age but
nazis are bad
uh ouch
oh my gosh
it's all right come on we got married
since you
since we lost you
what the [ __ ]
what no you have to come with us i cut a
deal that when i got right
that i would call vort they were going
to come and take him away and that you'd
never [ __ ] see him
oh you're doing the right thing butcher
[ __ ] me uh i couldn't do it he's not
gonna kill baby ryan
[Laughter]
uh-oh did i hear you say butcher
[Laughter]
where's my son
oh where
is my son what do you guys think you
could do today
i don't want to pass my [ __ ] on it don't
say that you have to come with
oh
god it feels like the show's ending or
something
we know there's a season three so it's
insane
oh no so it's gonna happen yeah
something that's gonna happen i can feel
it
oh shoot oh no
no oh no
she says the truth is she's gonna stick
her boot up
oh here we go here we go
unlock your hidden potential
no [ __ ] way
i don't believe it
come on they did not just offer like
that
she's gotta have some no she's gotta be
like alive still right you can just kill
a little next step
it's a good day to be alive get in there
maeve
girl power up that nazi [ __ ]
oh yeah yes yes
that [ __ ] yes oh she's getting her oh my
god yes
yes yes
yeah fly fly fly away
oh goody come here ryan
oh no she's snapping
take the [ __ ] away from my son we love
you ryan
oh yeah oh my god yes
dude ryan's gonna murder stormfront oh
my
[ __ ] oh ryan murderer
laser ryan
there's that hate
did he do it did he laser the right
person i know i'm a little concerned
she's muttering
it's darth vader
i'm sorry i'm sorry
what oh no
how would that have done it though a
beam got in the way
oh man
oh no
damn oh
dude if if he didn't do anything
stormfront would have killed her yeah
take a good look homelander
here
oh my god i'm gonna throw you off a
skyscraper
come here
what a beautiful image
oh god have it your way
stop and what
are you doing here
making up for a season
i'll destroy everything and everyone
great as long as everyone sees what a
[ __ ] monster you are
he is such a good actor i know man he's
[ __ ] incredible oh gosh
oh butcher
we believe that stormfront was a sole
perpetrator of the attack on washington
oh thanks to the heroism of
queen maeve and starlight
[Laughter]
is being held in an undisclosed
stormfront's violation of that special
relationship
that trust
he has snapped own bin gentlemen
thank you for always happy to see you
sir
i'm afraid we had it
private data reserved no one saw the
thief come or go
isn't that right hatred
that was you dude i didn't know sir [ __ ]
him i would never go by
you're back in [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
but not you deep because starlight's
back in i'm back too
right right i'm anti-nazi i'm sorry
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] peace out [ __ ]
he's self-absorbed
because you said you'd get me back in
the seven you [ __ ] promised
i'm sorry but you are acting like a
toxic personality i think you should
leave
[ __ ] fresco
someone taught me something about
hanging in there
who's that here's huey i've been
thinking about that
lately they're hanging in there i'm
gonna quit
i think it's time to go off
stand on my own two feet for once what
does that mean
spin-off called the boy
[Laughter]
we'll just be friends then oh oh god no
no no i'm still going to cling on to you
i'm not [ __ ] crazy
that's his most charming moment all
season
[Laughter]
now remember what i told you
don't be
[Laughter]
checking in with him he can't keep him
safe
william i'm so sorry victoria newman is
the new czar
she's sneaking me some off the books
funding for a team that can keep
tabs on the soups interesting
[Music]
oh they're not fugitives anymore at
least until
season three
oh no god ew
oh god
you have enough dirt to ruin a dozen
soups
oh wow of course if you're open to uh
expediting the church's tax exempt
status
oh no so yeah
i do love frisco
[Music]
rock on man that was great
no [ __ ] way
it's her
oh my god
[Music]
no
we all predicted it wow wow
look the truth is i never totally fit in
with the guys
and i think it's time i
stand on my own two feet definitely not
gonna get in trouble working with her
man
he just stumbled right into the right
where can i start
wow that is a great twist that's a great
twist yeah
wow
[Music]
dude they killed it
[Music]
that was a fantastic season two finale
that was a fantastic it like
made the whole season just come together
yeah
that was a really great season season
finale like it just made me love the
whole season that much more [ __ ]
all right bye that
was not only the best episode of the boy
season two
i think it's one of the best episodes of
the boys generally speaking and i think
it made
the whole season just that much better i
either liked or loved everything here
there wasn't i didn't have a single
issue with the way anything
went down or character portrayals i was
like i'm all for frenchie
kimiko in the end it was really
surprised me
because the way season one ended it
doesn't end on a happy
note and not everything is happy here
the main takeaway is the cliffhanger of
the season one ending that you're like
okay i gotta finish season two but even
though there's cliffhangers here
are like some obvious ones that we gotta
talk a little bit about at least it
still felt like they completed a story
yeah i love when a season does that like
to me that's the way i feel like most
seasons should go with
a lot of tv it's like have your
cliffhanger so we want to tune in for
season three but at the same time
make it feel like you completed a tale
and i really thought they knocked it out
of the park
i feel like we're all in unison i feel
like we all thought this was pretty
great now i know
you know it's like yeah should we talk
about the congresswoman first
you know oh the one with the head
exploding or uh homelander becca dying
i want to start with this maeve
that might not be the one everyone wants
to start off with we're talking about
but we've said our [ __ ] about me all
right
in the moment when we said it
full-heartedly
felt that okay i'm not taking that back
in the moment however
watching her hear like oh dude you have
like you had one of the most defined
arcs
out of anyone in in this uh season in
particular she wants to
uh not be in hiding anymore she's kind
of cowering away and then she's stripped
away from elena
and she starts diverting back to more
older habits and then here she she comes
into her own here she becomes a badass
stands up for herself and then she
stands up to homelander at the end good
for you maeve
yeah quite quite gratifying yeah like
over the course of the season i know
we've had a lot of gripes about the way
your character's been handled but
especially seeing how everything wrapped
up it did lend some credence to me to
the idea that like this character is so
far down a hole because you know she's
are
arguably one of the main seven and so
you would think that she's kind of been
in this position for a long time and so
yeah watching her
be beleaguered and stripped down to the
point where she doesn't care anymore i
thought she drove that home pretty well
and it was really triumph like
every time she showed up this episode
just to help i was just so overjoyed you
know
and you said during it that she's become
your new favorite character
yeah i really enjoy her now i'm also
surprised homelander didn't just kill
her
then and there what i loved about the
handling of that moment
like you hear excuse the light guys it's
gonna keep happening throughout the
review we're in the living room
it's windy outside and also blazing hot
simultaneously
so you're gonna see his light just
flashing over all three of our faces
during this time
homelanders being reminded of like he
hears the chanting of homelander and now
that he's being stripped of everything
he's lost stormfront he's losing he
could lose ryan he craves love and
attention
the love from the people is all he could
latch onto in that moment
her saying to him like as long as the
world no one loves you anymore
like that just hit home so hard for him
i thought that was like a
perfect line to make sure you get that
final nail in the coffin so that way she
that way he doesn't just turn on her and
murder her right then and there but yeah
i was actually
surprised by how there was a lot of
happy wrap-ups with so many of these
character
even once who wasn't exactly happy or
positive there was this
vibe about it that was oh we're actually
some of us are winning this time
awesome and the bad guys are going down
cool all right so which one you want to
talk about first babe
adrien a train a train adrie's storyline
was really good
you got him getting revenge on
stormfront
especially once you find out she's a
nazi and i like him sticking it to the
deep so that was perfect for me oh god
and their whole back and forth
yeah i love it i love the way that they
and it's only little moments but
especially the way the deep is just
it's so petty yeah entirely petty like
the second there's doubt he's just like
hey
i hate this guy now he's so childlike
yeah
hyper reactive it kept feeling like they
were setting up the convergence for
something more for season three
with the way how that went down for the
head of i don't think it's being
set up for season three necessarily well
the churches is gonna
need a new head
[Laughter]
the way that whole scene went down and
with atria getting in there i loved how
all this season it's like oh the deep's
uh working on his redemption path the
deep's getting back to the public
spotlight the deep's gonna try to get
back in the
end he loses yes and to adrian who like
the whole time doesn't seem to invest or
care at
all yeah and like the second he gets
reinstated he's just like
peace i'm out yeah storm front oh
she suffered good that was great to
watch but she's still alive yes
they said she's in an undisclosed
location yeah contained in some
undisclosed location or something so
she's come back
as darth vader next season but yeah
right now to look like anakin skywalker
in episode three the thing though is
she's like horribly disfigured her image
is completely ruined in the public
spotlight but in the end stormfront
lost and i think that's what the
rewarding cathartic part about it
is especially when the girl power scene
shows up that's how you do girl power in
comic books yeah you said stunt man mike
it is like
uh tarantino's death proof and that's in
that moment where all three of them
are just pounding on earth and that's he
just had me going
it's like do they like they kill
chemical but chemical can't just
die by her having her next thing she
can't die like that right can she die in
general
well she has super strength so like her
dying by a neck snap just wasn't making
sense to me at the time i was about to
be mad at the show if there wasn't gonna
make a moment out of it but then like
maeve
showing up and then starlight standing
her ground and all three of them just
working together and i love like
watching the the
boys who were there at the time off to
the sidelines just like
amazed at what they were watching the
whole time yeah the whole scene just
felt very cathartic it felt like a
really rewarding moment
one it goes to i think solidify that
because you have that bit about
everyone's beefing up with the guns and
everything and they're like we're gonna
kill them all and then yeah it's
sure enough not any of them you know and
so you further earned that moment it's
like
it's a cool moment to take a little bit
of the piss out of you know the
reference moment and game but also yeah
a moment where you really do
feel like damn good on all of you
because stormfront has been a detriment
to
each of you in a totally different way
because you're each in three different
positions on this totem pole i like
starfront getting her ass handed to her
um i think it was well deserved i like
maeve coming in for the safe that turned
the tide because
stormfront was beating them all up and
then maeve comes in and
yeah we see more of maeve's powers every
time
she really turned the tables with black
noir
and now with a storm front they would
have gotten their asses beat if she
hadn't showed up
and i will say too in terms of that
fight scene i think boys season one got
criticism for how they handled their
fight choreography
and especially the way it was captured
on camera and i thought that that was
one of the better
better ones they've ever put together
just the whole thing leading up to it
and the whole sequence is going down man
[ __ ] storefront i love when she like
walked in a vod and everyone's giving
her the bad luck
everyone's like the night this show did
such a good job at making you go
i hate start [ __ ] i hate start burning
and then this last episode made you go
yeah
[ __ ] you star friend suffer
definitely rewarding very enriching
sense of like you mad bro watching like
a villain who's
really pissed because they know they've
been had like yeah it's so gratifying
although i do think it was funny when
frenchie yells let's go get that weapon
out of here
[Laughter]
pretend you're running for cover no but
yeah that was a great scene i love that
all that stuff would butcher um and
becca
that was like getting me emotional yeah
well i think that's the way that you
really nuance that whole thing with
stormfront because i think that if we
had just gotten a beatdown
and no consequence you know it might
have felt a little
less hefty but the fact that you have
that whole mess with ryan and becca and
butcher
as a crucial element of that i thought
yeah really elevated it and i think it
brought a different emotional
turn to what we just witnessed right
away we see storefronts
goes to butcher and becca yeah and when
she gets stabbed in the eye though what
a great moment
just toot my own horn i remember saying
that becca's gonna die this season
doesn't a narcissist toot their own
horns yeah i'm a narcissist
and you also called that a train was
gonna help yeah and uh
john is uh here to help with enabling
him
you are so great at prediction let me
tell you more
those scenes of becco like when beck and
butch are going back and forth and then
like the way especially the last episode
was going down with how butcher
was uh responding to his family his
parents
having that moment where he's doing the
right thing it's like it's
it's a great arc because they
established earlier that
you know he can't be a dad to ryan
there's no way that he could ever accept
this kid
and then at the end he's making that
deal with edgar
you're like god it's such a butcher
thing to do i actually
wasn't expecting him to do the right
thing
i thought he would kill yeah that's how
good a prediction say i
i thought he was gonna kill ryan he
really did
he's gonna do something he's gonna ruin
this relationship in some way man
i'm curious that the huge turn ryan
takes there at the end because
homelander didn't really say anything
at the beginning to get ryan not on his
side so why didn't ryan go to homeland
or does that make sense
the main thing that i took from that is
that homelander brought stormfront
and because of that and then the clear
way in which homelander always shows
that he clearly seems to be much more
into and about stored front than becca
at all
and he also i feel like ryan's been at
least
witness to enough tensions or or
something between uh a homelander
he just had that bonding moment though
with homelander to me that was a little
strange like the second he goes
you're gonna go with this little [ __ ]
who killed your wife i'm like oh that
would make sense but he was already over
there at that
point you know that was the only thing
that kind of threw me off
i mean i loved it i loved the moment
don't get me wrong but i think it just
to me it was a little strange because
homelander didn't do anything he saw a
stone
stormfront burn their crisp and he was
like but he didn't go how could you do
this
you know he was like okay come here
let's go i feel like ryan was able to
pick up on the fact that he obviously
had to choose either between his mom and
homelander and his mom
chose butcher and i think he picked up
on that fact
i mean that's all i took from it you
know it's hard to do authentic
children especially in the writing i
think and i did at least
appreciate some of that confusion they
brought up with him especially when
becca comes back he's like i'm sorry i
didn't mean to say those things that i
said last time when i found out my life
is a lie
while i'm sure it could have been
somewhat perhaps more fleshed out or
natural i did think that they did a
decent job with him
and his circumstances overall and just
the confusion
i really do wonder if he is the one who
injured becca though because
we saw what he did to stormfront becca
didn't have any burns on her
yeah she had like a clean cut on her
throat where stormfront was holding her
so i'm almost curious if that's going to
be like a reveal that he actually didn't
kill his mom that's true because to me
the wounds don't match
what he did to storm front yeah i was
curious about that too yeah i don't know
the blast might have been so big that it
but
yeah there was no real burn mark either
way i mean the wish is dead
we'll find out those answers next season
but i thought the performance
uh both um forgive me for not knowing
the actress's name
but becca and butcher i thought
that they're performing both all their
scenes together and especially that
moment just that conflict
all all the on the eyes and the face a
butcher of
when becca dies and then he has the kid
right there
and you just feel this conflict you can
feel it all
like i have to take care of him this is
what becca wants but i also kind of hate
this kid
you know yeah and i feel like you
physically watch the decision
form as the kid steps close to you yeah
he doesn't know what he's going to do or
what to do
until ryan chooses him oh that was
beautiful and becca's acting
she immediately she goes it's not his
fault oh my god
like she used her dying words to save
him
like oh her dying words to save him
first because she
knows she knew how butcher would respond
make sure he knows and you know yeah it
is not his fault
you know that was such a brilliant
acting and it was brilliant writing
because
quite honestly becca's had nowhere to go
from here
if she got ryan back then went off this
makes it more interesting and whatnot
yeah
absolutely i completely agree especially
for going forward also speaking of the
laser moment i love the the top the wrap
around with that when they're trying to
t
when homelanders trying to teach imagine
someone you can imagine someone you hate
and then
he finds he finds someone to hate and
then the lasers come out of him so cool
i i thought the pacing of this episode
was so
well earned like from because it starts
off really taking its time
and it's just slowly building and things
just start and like in the halfway point
when stormfront shows up or
once they start going after your
homeland or the farm and try to get try
to get ryan out of there
they just the pacing of it just ramps
perfectly
up escalating to like just real tense
like
what's gonna happen moments you know
like who's gonna do what right now
you know uh and i appreciate that
technically i i totally
missed whoever directed this episode
whatever did they they killed it here
yeah they they knocked it out of the
park i think every little bit was great
and needed to the storyline there wasn't
a wasted scene here
every bit of it was important and if
like at the very beginning you know
like the boys gathering around becco was
so sweet sometimes the episodes could
feel a little bit imbalanced to me at
times
that's the thing is when you get to a
season finale of a of a show
specifically like this
is you kind of have to look at the whole
package and not so much individual
episodes sometimes and
in terms of the whole package every once
in a while and it would be like i care
more about the soups than i do
watching the boys themselves and
sometimes like ah the boys were really a
highlight and the soups were not as
interesting and this one was like about
both and i thought it handled it
perfectly well and it also did a good
job of addressing a lot of those
questions i remember people having
earlier on in the season especially like
with
stan edgar and actually him confronting
like here's why i tolerate stormfront
here's the full
exactly behind my position at this
company and you know
i like that they've kept him as somewhat
of a peripheral character because it
makes him
a very distinct presence every time he's
on and like when he had that whole
meeting with butcher like i thought that
was a beautifully acted scene like every
one of his scenes
yeah and all of his dealings and you see
like just how far
out his feelers are spread oh it's seen
with him and the convergence guy too
that was that was really relaxed as well
even huey and starlight we've given them
[ __ ] this season
we're giving them so much [ __ ] this year
and then it's just my mom like
hell yeah that was a great moment i'm
happy you too i made it work
they explained the billy joel yeah i got
even yeah
like you said that was one of the cutest
moments for them all season with that
mislead with huey and the whole like i
gotta let go of some people
which is not you you know mother's milk
has been trying to get home to his
family for two seasons now but he
finally does
yeah yeah only to to leave them at the
start of the next one
even kimiko and frenchie like i i love
the way how those last moments were
kind of playing out a little bit like a
silent film the way i went down with
butcher and
ryan i thought that was a perfect ending
button i feel like we'll still check in
with ryan eventually
i think we're not done with ryan's story
obviously he's going to grow up to be
jensen ackles you guys
then everyone's going to be really old
next 30-year time trump
i feel like butcher was able to find
some type of peace
with the existence of ryan in a way how
would you describe
the nuance of that scene i feel it was
more of a respect between the two
given when he hands over the the charm
the saint christopher whatever i don't
for you know gives it to him
i think that was more of a okay i
accept you in a way yeah and how much
becca
i feel like it was a respect thing and
sort of a commitment to that like hey
i want to at least while i'm here for a
minute empower you or yeah make you feel
something
warm and human yeah that becca would
have wanted
and and yeah watching that i thought
that was a really beautiful thing for
him because butcher like he's an easily
likable character he's the badass and
stuff but to have it come down to this
really tough
moral situation that doesn't end up with
him just like becoming ryan's dad
but at the same time yeah accepting him
losing becca
and you know i feel like there may be a
sort of stillness of closure because
i don't know thinking realistically i
don't think he and becca could have had
a life
no no no there was no way yeah and so as
a means of
conflict and and character like rough
character growth yeah i thought all that
with ryan and becca did a lot for
butcher i was just so taken aback by how
so the bad guys lost most of them lost
even a homeland or
lost you know i was that was the last
thing i was expecting this season two
to end on and then they're back
starlight's back in the seven yeah yeah
her reputation is fixed the boys are no
longer fugitives
homelander has to continue to put up his
the front he's miserable
striving for whatever ego as he touches
himself at the top of some building
he's he's just gone to his lowest point
the convergence guy gets his head blown
off
and then now that's where all the i just
love how he was like you know
i need to go off on my own and do my own
thing and i never really fit in quite
with the boys and now he's working
for the person responsible for
annihilating all these people and he has
no idea
what he's on the brink of uncovering now
really
showing i guess how dirty everything is
from the inside he's just like
there's a universe that pulls him
towards just this little like
crime stuff that he doesn't really want
to get mixed up in
well this was interesting to me because
i don't know the comics obviously
and how closely they are following the
arcs but this seemed to me like i know
in the comics the book the boys are
like you know a cia little group and it
seemed like almost that this season
clinched their formation as like okay
like
we're this team that is going to be kind
of keeping soups in check
yeah and from here on out that's kind of
going to be our official goal whereas up
until
this point they felt like a ragtag group
off
the books you know unofficial this
season seemed to really go after
all these alt-right sides right all
right that's not my interpretation it's
a [ __ ] apparent get mad if you want
to the whole time all right
and the two-facedness of so many
organizations that claim to be
for the benefit of people yeah you know
this character who
like represents sort of alexander acosta
cortez gotta have one
so do you think they'd be going after
the liberal side and the boys season
three ah
that's a great question if they paint
her as a bat because
because they don't really explain her is
gonna come back and be the hero next
season oh god
they don't really explain why she was
doing what she was doing
so that's what we have to uncover quite
honestly i'm glad the church guy got his
head blown off so
that's what i mean like she like she off
people but then like she killed
the good cia person at the beginning of
the at the of the show
so it's like why did she kill certain
people with some stuff just to cover up
curious it's like we like obviously like
oh she killed some pretty bad people
that
yeah they had it coming but then there's
other people like but why'd she kill
those people
they didn't seem like they were bad so
uh that's what i mean like is she gonna
be
a villain for next season or is she some
like secret soup vigilante hero
or of sorts you know it'd be very very
interested to see and i wonder even if
they might
take some kind of stance of yeah doing
the exact
sort of opposite of a storm front where
it's like here's somebody who's willing
to go just as
far but for a different perhaps slightly
more
outside accessible idea for the for the
other side
so the two extremes of of the same coin
essentially and then the show loses all
its viewers
because they've attacked a whole all
right and then
the liberals and then black newmar he's
fine yeah he'll recover
he'll recover hopefully he doesn't have
brain damage we didn't get any verdict
on that so who knows
to sum it up i thought all the emotional
beats
really hit every scene was fleshed out
perfectly shouts out to homelander
daddying his kid
relating with him there on the couch
like there was
every scene i thought was pitch perfect
it it got me
pretty emotional at times it was
exciting zillow rating
perfected the whole rest of season two
every character i loved
like literally this was the best episode
of season two and there wasn't a single
thing i would really i would change
about it yeah i thought it was
pitch perfect i'm glad we're on the same
page
happy campers all right guys well what
did you think of the boys season two
finale what'd you think of the whole
season in total do you prefer it over
season one i still need time to ruminate
and think about that myself
subscribe click that notification bell
last but not least
deontay w tongue punch fart box you know
what man
if there's anyone who would stick their
tongue
in a fart box it would be homelander for
you buddy
he would call your anus
the home touchdown yeah the home
the home front the home where he wants
to lay down
sports analogy here um it's the home run
zone home run that's the word i'm
looking for
and he's gonna punch you with his tongue
so much right in your home run zone we
could have just done an acronym shout
out for what deontay means
but your name's too fun man yeah man
tongue punch fart box i mean that sounds
like a finishing move
you know what you know homelander will
be down for it dude
and then more you know i mean don't stop
at tongue punching with the fart box i
mean
go all the way i'm talking solids
liquids
all the above okay fine let's do this
again deontay
d stands for tongue punch fart box
[Music]
you